yeah summertime render I think is the
other really overlooked anime I've seen
I've seen a couple of episodes of that
yeah again I did want to watch it it
looked sick yeah it looked like uh it's
not on Netflix it's on Disney plus
though it's a Disney it's on Netflix
though that's why I think it's must be
must be in Japan it's definitely an I I
thought it would be uh Disney plus
exclusive at least he has English
subtitles with Disney plus uh because
For the Longest Time Disney kind of like
locked it away and was like no rest of
the world you can't watch summertime
render [__] JoJo all over again
that's why no one [__] talked about
it but yeah it's like re-zero uh it's I
was trying to think of something witty
but it's just like it's just [__]
re-zero it's all set in summer that's
basically it oh I'll go with that and
it's uh but it's hot
basically basically re-zero and
higarashi but he hasn't watching garage
oh you have okay I watched the dubbed we
had a conversation yeah that's all right
I watched the dubbed and that was a
mistake we [__] did you literally
watched one of the worst times
yeah what's going on with Reserve when
when is there another season coming
what's up with that uh oh I don't know I
mean it should take us so long I mean
nagatsuki is still riding it oh how many
REM figures do we have to move before
they they like surely the the re-zero
money pool must be infinite
like with the amount of REM figures
they've sold
um yeah but nagatsuki doesn't see barely
any of that [__] yeah well that's true
but anyway I thought I thought where
there was already there's already enough
material yeah no there is there is
uh what's the hold up I don't know man
hopefully it doesn't turn into a [__]
No Game No Life right like in it it only
feels like this happens in Japan where
there could be like an insane amount of
demand for something and just they just
don't do it yeah
dude if we had a re-zero in America dude
we would have 19 spin-offs yes yeah how
how Subaru got circumcised I'm just I'm
just playing the whole [__] story I'm
just praying they don't play No Game No
Life and give us a movie instead of a
season two I don't know some sometimes
sometimes Japan go for that [__]
Direction yeah like I don't but it's
always the shows that like weren't
really that popular right like it always
occurs be like why it's like spicy wolf
fans my first time it's like how many
[__] seasons of data live is there
now and I'm like who's still watching
that show someone is joking like someone
the [__] these people are who are making
Idol shows can someone get them over to
like the good shows because dude those
dudes know how to get shows made like
straight up they get shows mate no I
I'll tell you the difference I'll tell
you the [__] difference okay tell me
the [__] difference okay we lied to
clown on Idol fans and everything right
they spend their [__] money okay
sorry have we not spent enough money on
re-zero [__] how many REM there's a rem
every second in Japan a rem figure is
sold if not 10. well okay like you go on
Twitter and you see all of these Twitter
accounts complaining about like oh CG in
anime and like chainsaw man look like
this do you think they [__] paid for
that show [__] I guaranteed most of them
didn't even pay for anything I I have
not bought ten thousand dollar worth of
uh you know changing my merge I've
bought at least like two grand worth of
rams yeah you know
and I know my uh my other fellow uh
people who live here have yeah uh you
know every day when I whenever I go to
the crank game place I always see people
winning Rams you know the ram fund must
be deep why
as well like I just don't understand
like it doesn't make sense I'm just
saying idle fans [__] turn up man
for that [__] okay yeah I don't know
yeah that's I I I I honestly do I'm I'm
gonna make a prediction that they are
making more re-zero it just takes a long
[__] time to make anime
um I'm not appreciating it enough yeah
yeah I think one of the big issues right
now is just like every Anime Studio is
just Ram hooked up to capacity over
Cabana I'm gonna be sad if I'm like 40
when re-zero ends or some [__] what the
[__] is this a one-piece family
I mean I'm reading that right now it's
hard to do anything else when you read
one piece I'm not talking about it I
don't want to talk I I want to just wait
till I'm done but yeah it is it takes oh
yeah it does but I don't know that's
I've we have we have so many shows
coming out right now that sometimes I'm
just like okay a Show's just gonna if if
a show takes 10 years to finish
um if I could get through Evangelion
then I can get through anything you know
if I can wait well all of this time you
say that but I think like movies like
Avatar the weight like actually it was a
massive detriment I think to me caring
about anything
um well yes because just people have
shorter intentions no no I I don't I
don't think that the time period made a
difference if I've seen Avatar 2 by the
way yeah yeah I I have an opinion on
this era when I watched the newest
season last time it didn't mean to be
like all right yeah why do I give a [__]
again okay yeah yeah it's it's it can be
frustrating and I think that's what um I
know anime just takes a while right like
over Lord I just I just I just haven't
watched the new season because I'm like
it's not worth it I know I have watched
the new season like really yeah I
watched three seasons of Overlord right
and I loved I loved every every season I
watched but the thought of having to
remind myself to give a [__] again about
everything is like okay I just I dude I
can't yeah and I know because overlord's
a lot overloaded yeah it's very like
dense in its world and characters
um yeah I mean but it just makes it that
much harder to get back into it right
yeah you have to remind yourself again
about all those little details yeah yeah
for me for me it's like playing a jrpg
quitting halfway through the wanting to
play it again and getting back to the
game impossible I don't remember
anything impossible
Avatar it was like it was basically like
very easy kids story plot line yeah yeah
where stuff like Overlord and re-zero
feels like a lot to get back into and so
that's basically why I didn't watch
Overlord the new one and I don't really
think I will I don't think I care
anymore
yeah that too like I was just like I was
just like I don't want to sit through
this again
just take way too long to continue like
what was the break between the overlord
seasons was it like three years two
years just three years two years three
years is too much I think I don't know I
I feel like it could happen
um if
honestly 12 episodes is too much
honestly because the example I use right
the example I use Attack on Titan yeah
right between season one and season two
we had like a [__] five six year
break or something like that yeah it was
a long break and most of the everyone
thought that by the Time season two came
out everyone would stop giving a [__]
about attack on everyone kind of did
though everyone kind of did for a while
like for for like a little bit but I
felt like it wasn't until season three
where everyone started carrying again
but then you only really start caring
when the hype [__] starts happening yeah
yeah because the problem with something
like re-zero season two is that it was
it felt more like a setup season for
sure for sure and like you're like I
don't really care what's going on and I
don't really care to invest myself
because there's not really anything hype
happening but let's say re-zero season
three does happen I don't know what
happens further on and there are some
[__] Banger moments there are some
hype [__] happening you're gonna start
like oh [__] I wanna I wanna like care
about this again you know and I I feel
like something dense like Overlord my
big problem with Overlord in general
right now after watching season for is
that every season I'm I come in with the
same thing when I'm like oh I really
like the world and the characters and
waiting for like I'm I wait for that oh
[__] moment because it always feels like
it's building towards that oh [__]
moment and then it just doesn't deliver
the same way I want it to deliver 12
episodes just isn't enough for stuff
like Overlord I think I think it's too
the the overlord world is so dense like
you said that 12 episodes just feels
like you got like an itch of an arc yeah
it feels like you didn't get anything
yeah
um whereas when you compare it to like
let's say other like normal like live
action stuff in America it's like okay
well they might do 10 episodes but like
they're an hour long so you can really
get into some [__] I I think
just not like six what is 12 hours is
that like five hours of content four
hours of content 12 episodes yeah that's
like four hours it's about four and a
half yeah yeah
like four hours of content isn't that
much isn't that much for a really big
World building show like Overlord yeah
where they they hinted so much stuff and
it's like man it's like I can't even in
season three I was like wait who's who's
who again yeah and you hinted at this a
little bit in season one I'm like what
yeah I'm It's just tough to care it is
it is and I want to I really want to
care I like I like Overlord I like the
world it was sick yeah yeah yeah because
it's yeah it's it's it's a really sick
world and there's a lot going on which
is like like I said something that I
always liked about overlords and it's
always felt like it built up towards
something yeah and then when yeah it
just you know it's good when there's
like multiple channels uploading lore
videos about Overlord yeah and there's
so many of them and they're good and
you're like well this is actually
[__] interesting yeah which honestly
sometimes if I just need a recap I'll
just like watch a recap yeah it's good
it's good yeah that's that's normally
enough for me because normally what I
find a lot of the times with big open
worlds like this is that for like the
important story beats 90 of the
information isn't isn't like necessarily
necessary it's necessary if you really
really want to immerse yourself in the
world before like the core basic story
beats of this epic thing is happening
what do I need to know going into this
beforehand you can normally like you
know just you know read a [__] Wiki
uh well yeah to get up to date that
makes you just think about like Game of
Thrones where it's like yeah you can
have the service level plot points yeah
enjoy it or you can really get in the
world building and get [__] lost in
how good the world is exactly how that
will interact yeah and I feel like that
it's just hard to do that with a lot of
anime yeah I'd rather I'd I'd rather die
and lose both my arms than read a visual
novel I'm just not I'm not I mean
yeah I'm not doing it yeah I can't I
can't read a visual knowledge yeah I can
only imagine the writing yeah oh my God